well ladies and gentlemen as the
Premier's indicated this is a difficult
day for everyone that's involved in this
particular operation I can confirm for
you that we have a an armed defender in
premises holding an undisclosed number
of hostages in the city in the Martin
Place area police have been in
attendance and have controlled the
situation from very early this morning
shortly after it was advised we are at
this stage continuing to secure and make
sure that we're doing all we can to
bring this to a peaceful outcome we want
this matter resolved peacefully and we
will do what we need to to ensure that
what we have also is a number of
incidents that people believe may be
connected to the city event and that's
not the case we've got a lot of people
that are out there concerned when they
see a police vehicle drive down their
street to think that their suburb or
their Shire might be involved that's not
the case we are very contained
we certainly have tight restrictions and
truck controls around that location and
we will work as long as we need to to
bring this to an outcome the officers
that are there are well trained and
professional they know what they're
doing they have trained for this and I'm
sure that they will get through and this
will be an outcome that will be will be
positive we also are aware that there
are many people that have been displaced
yes we have evacuated some of the
immediate surrounds and we've done that
for a reason we want to do all we can to
ensure that people do not get harmed
transport arrangements as the premier
has indicated have been put into place
and we need to make sure that people can
get in and out of the city the city is
still operating and will continue to
operate until we need to change that so
at this stage it is well contained our
thoughts our prayers go out to those
that are caught up in this we are doing
absolutely everything we can to resolve
it there are well trained officers
Institute doing the job they will I am
sure bring this to some conclusion
successfully just as soon as we possibly
can
and transport arrangements as the
premier has indicated our in place so
that people can leave the city